the human guts can be the scene for
devastating conditions such as
inflammatory bowel disease which arises
through an improperly controlled immune
response the gut is often the body's
first point of contact with microbes
every mouthful of food is accompanied by
a cargo of microorganisms that go on to
encounter the mucosa the innermost layer
of the gut most microbes are destroyed
by the harsh acidic environment in the
stomach but a hardy few make it through
to the intestine the intestinal surface
is covered with finger-like protrusions
called villi whose primary function is
the absorption of nutrients
however these structures and the
underlying tissues also host the body's
largest population of immune cells
scattered along the intestinal mucosa
are dome-like structures called peyer's
patches these are enriched in lymphoid
tissue making them key sites for
coordinating immune responses to
pathogens whilst promoting tolerance to
harmless microbes and food the villi
contain a network of blood vessels to
transport nutrients from food to the
rest of the body lymphatics from both
the peyer's patches and villi drain into
the mesenteric lymph node within the
villi is a network of loose connective
tissue called the lamina propria and at
the base of the villi are the crypts
which host stem cells that replenish the
epithelium finally the epithelium
together with its thick overlying mucous
forms an important barrier against
microbial invasion
embedded within the matrix of the payers
patch is a mix of immune cells including
T and B lymphocytes macrophages and
dendritic cells a key function of the
payers patch is the sampling of antigens
in this case mostly bacteria and bits of
food to facilitate this the payers patch
has a much thinner mucous layer as well
as specialized phagocytic cells called M
cells which can transport material
across the epithelial barrier via a
process called transit ptosis
finally dendritic cells are able to
extend dendrites between epithelial
cells to sample antigens that are then
broken down and used for presenting to
lymphocytes sampling antigens in this
way typically results in so-called
tolerate any activation where the immune
system initiates an anti-inflammatory
response with their cargo of antigen
these dendritic cells then traffic to
the T cell zones of the payers patch
upon encounter with specific T cells the
dendritic cells convert them into an
immunomodulatory cell called a
regulatory t-cell or T reg defects in
the function of these cells are
associated with inflammatory bowel
disease in both animals and humans these
T regs then migrate to the lamina
propria of the villi via the lymphatics
here the T regs secrete a molecule
called il-10 which exerts a suppressive
action on immune cells within the lamina
propria and upon the epithelial layer
itself il turn is therefore critical in
maintaining immune quiescence and
preventing unnecessary inflammation
however a breakdown in this process of
immune homeostasis results in gut
pathology and when this occurs over a
prolonged period and in an uncontrolled
manner it can lead to inflammatory bowel
disease chemical mechanical or pathogen
triggered barrier disruption coupled
with particular genetic susceptibilities
may all combine to set off inflammation
epithelium coming into contact with
bacteria is activated leading to
bacterial influx alarm molecules
released by the epithelium activate
immune cells and tear eggs in the
vicinity scale down their il-10
secretion to enable an immune response
to proceed dendritic cells are also
activated by this environment and start
to release key inflammatory molecules
such as il-6 il-12 and il-23 effective
t-cells also appear on the scene and
these coordinate an escalation of the
immune response by secreting their own
inflammatory molecules tumor necrosis
factor alpha interferon gamma and il-17
soon after the affected t-cells have
arrived
a voracious Vega site called a
neutrophil is recruited neutrophils are
critical for the clearance of bacteria
one weapon in the neutrophil armory is
the ability to undergo dramatic form of
self destruction called neurosis this
leaves behind a jumble of DNA saturated
with enzymes called a neutrophil
extracellular trap although this can
effectively destroy bacterial invaders
and plug in E breaches in the apathy
lleol wall it also causes collateral
damage to tissues
slowly the tide begins to turn and the
bacterial invasion is repulsed any
remaining neutrophils die off via
apoptosis a non inflammatory form of
cell death and are cleared by
macrophages epithelial integrity is
restored by replacement of any damaged
cells with new ones from the intestinal
crypts finally tear eggs are recruited
once again to calm the immune response
targeting the molecules involved in gut
pathology is leading to effective
therapies for inflammatory bowel disease
you